But another time I fought,
I used to,
I used to take the number one bus from Jersey City Rothberg into high school and
we were on the bus one morning kids and there was a guy reading a paper and he
had a connector of drool from his Lyft to the daily news and there was a puddle,
he was on heroin.
They would go to Jersey City in those days and get methadone.
So they would take the bus up northwest.
So I'm sitting there,
he's passed the fuck out and there's got to be just six inches of poplar.
This guy's been passed out for 20 minutes.
I point my ass at him and I lift up my hips and a little bit,
I kept my asshole just pointing out that even if it wasn't pointed at him,
he wouldn't ricochet off the chair and go straight through his mouth.
Like he's sitting there and I let her fuck go out.
I could live to be 80 he lifted his eyes like this person,
right?
Hey,
one cause mouth.
Who the fuck?
He goes,
these as and died.
And my little buddies were like,
what the fuck and Giggling,
and he's like,
I should beat the fuck out of whatever farther.
I'm just mother.
Fantastic.
Oh,
Jesus.
Oh Man.
This is when,
this is why I hate people.
This is why I hate when I read posts.
Gimme a second.